on y revient tout de suite avec l'invité
de paris direct
[Musique]
et s'est invité chez vous antoine
jackowski bonjour bonjour merci d'être
sur ce plateau vous êtes historien
spécialiste des relations russo
ukrainiennes co directeur du département
de recherche politique et religion du
collège des bernardins c'était donc dans
la nuit du 23 au 24 février dernier
vladimir poutine annoncé le lancement de
son opération spéciale en ukraine une
invasion déclenché à l'aube s'en étaient
suivis on s'en souvient des
bombardements à marioupol à odessa akram
à tort ce qu'à kiev moscou disait
vouloir des nazis fiifi l'ukraine et la
démilitarisé trois mois plus tard quel
bilan
globalement c'est un échec c'est cette
invasion russe c'est un échec dramatique
parce que rien que du côté ukrainien on
considère qu'il ya dix morts
par jour
par ailleurs pardon dit mort par heure
ça veut dire plus de 30000 morts rien
que du côté ukrainien
les ukrainiens considère que du côté
russe on approche plus de 30000 soldats
russes tombé sur le front donc c'est
dramatique et à des centaines de
milliers de blessés 6 millions de
réfugiés du côté ukrainien à l'étranger
sans parler des déplacements internes et
des dizaines de milliards de dollars de
destructions
donc voilà c'est dramatique et pourquoi
finalement une ville prise une grande
ville prise
carson une autre ville marioupol
complètement détruite donc c'est pas du
tout une ni démilitarisation denis
dénazification au contraire la russie
s'est présenté comme un état violent
voire totalitaire timothy sneijder
l'historien américain 10 est un état
fasciste donc voilà cca une énorme
boucherie c'est les mots de joe biden
pour parler de de poutine et et le monde
qui tremble parce que on l'a vu avec
votre reportage sur tchernobyl
il ya bien évidemment d'un danger
nucléaire dans cette guerre il ya sept
centrales nucléaires de base aux stades
de nerfs godard
et
on craint un danger imminent dans les
premiers jours de guerre moscou penser
que kiev allait tomber très vite et
qu'il allait pouvoir placer un
gouvernement à sa solde dans la capitale
ukrainienne kiev a résisté on le disait
les forces concentrent à présent son
combat sur le don basm effectivement ou
va vladimir poutine on s'est toujours
pas très bien alors et le problème c'est
que on n'écoute pas beaucoup les
expertises il se trouve que moi pendant
deux ans j'ai j'ai organisé une
commission qui réunissait des russes et
des ukrainiens
avec des européens pour expliquer ce qui
se passait c'est à dire que c'était une
vraie guerre que c'était pas du tout une
guerre civile comme on le présentait
beaucoup en occident
en disant voilà on parlait des
séparatistes du donbass donc c'était une
vraie guerre une guerre qui menace l
identité de l'ukraine elle même puisque
aujourd'hui on voit bien que l'ancien
président medvedev parle de
déshumaniser l'ukraine donc c'est une
vraie guerre et on avait fait un certain
nombre de propositions pour dire comment
sortir de ce conflit de civilisation
avec d'un côté une logique impériale qui
ressemble un peu à l'origine la logique
impériale de l' empire allemand en 1870
et d'un autre côté la logique d'un
état-nation la logique ukrainienne qui
était celle de la france que défendent
ernest renan en 1882 et et ça on n'a pas
entendu et parce qu'on ne l'a pas
entendu on n'a pas cherché à le soigner
et aujourd'hui est bien le président
macron dit il ne faut pas humilier la
russie c'est à dire qu'il s'imagine déjà
en 1919 au moment du congrès de
versailles alors qu'on n'est pas au
congrès de versailles on serait si
vraiment il fallait faire une analogie
en 1941 quand l'angleterre était la
seule moment de la bataille d'angleterre
a lutté contre hitler et donc si on né
en 1941 et pas en 1919 et si en face il
ya un état qui est devenu totalitaire en
raison du fait qu'il n'a pas juger les
crimes du communisme
le communisme il n'est pas terminé comme
on l'a cru un peu naïvement à 91
puisqu'il n'a pas à juger ces crimes ils
les répètent et donc face à un
gouvernement totalitaire on peut pas
dire il faut éviter de de l'humilier il
faut le vaincre et donc c'est ça la
difficulté c'est que on ne sait pas qui
est la dîmière poutine on s'imagine que
c'est voilà un chef d'état qui défend
les intérêts de son sa nation en réalité
c'est bien plus grave que ça c'est un
homme qui a cette nostalgie de l' empire
qui veut le rétablir au 21ème siècle
alors qu'au xxième siècle cette logique
là n'est pas n'est pas durable et
surtout elle est gravissime elle peut
conduire vrai véritablement une guerre
mondiale omm qui dit que la plus grande
catastrophe du xxème siècle c'est la
chute de l'urss et comment
eh bien d'abord on le vin en étant
extrêmement ferme en expliquant ces
actions c'est ce que font les américains
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
écouté pendant des mois on n'a pas
écouté pendant des mois et je dirais que
en occident les services de
renseignement et notamment en france on
en parle on était aveuglé par une sorte
de russes au centrisme donc ça c'est un
premier problème donc là ce qu'il faut
c'est non seulement pour lutter contre
cette guerre hybride devenu
conventionnelles annoncées à l'avancé
qui va faire et on sait ce qu'il va
faire parce qu'il est dans cette logique
du tout au rien il a mis toute sa
carrière en jeu donc il va aller
jusqu'au bout il faut être conscient du
danger et il faut aussi du coup soutenir
fermement les ukrainiens puisque c'est
eux qui sont prêts à comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure m la vie de leurs
concitoyens pour lutter pour défendre
leur indépendance pas simplement de
l'ukraine mais de toute l'europe parce
que vladimir poutine l'a dit lavrov l'a
dit les après après l'ukraine ça
pourrait être la pologne ça pourrait
être les pays baltes c'est l'ensemble de
la construction européenne qui est en
danger donc il faut être conscient de ça
il faut soutenir les ukrainiens pour
qu'ils récupèrent
leur territoire et surtout pour
affaiblir le pouvoir russe comme l'a dit
le ministre de la défense américain et
ça malheureusement on en n'est pas
suffisamment conscients parce qu'il ya
déjà des articles qui paraissent
dans le new york times la semaine
dernière pour dire bon est-ce qu'il faut
vrai véritablement que les ukrainiens
récupèrent leur territoire est ce que ce
serait pas plus simple cette ligne qui
va de kharkov à carson et qu'on leur
donne ces territoires là le président
macron a commencé à dire que ça
prendrait des décennies avant de
l'intégrer l'ukraine dans l'union
européenne
à mon avis c'est un véritable danger
parce que ce serait pour le coup
reproduire les erreurs des de la
première guerre mondiale
qui on l'a vu l'alsace et la lorraine
dans l' empire allemand ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça n'a pas fonctionné qui
aujourd'hui voudraient donner l'alsace
et la lorraine à l'allemagne donc voilà
il faut être extrêmement ferme soutenir
cette coalition de rammstein qui a
encore s'est réuni la semaine dernière
et soutenir surtout l'opposition russe
je suis mais sidéré par le fait que
personne
ne porte attention à l'opposition
démocratique russe qui s'est réuni pas
plus tard qu'il ya quelques jours à
vilnius il ya eu zéro informations dans
les médias français alors que c'est la
principale chance de paix est la
principale chance de victoire contre
vladimir poutine quelques mots côté
ukrainien malheureusement le temps passe
très vite ce que cette invasion a
provoqué diriez vous comme on l'a
entendu ici et là la naissance d'une
nation dans le feu et dans le sens le
baptême d'une nation la confirmation
d'une nation pour reprendre une
métaphore je crois
si on parle de métaphore religieuse la
nation ukrainienne est très ancienne
elle a plus de mille ans le baptême de
la route comme on l'appelait 7 988 le
problème c'est que il ya eu finalement
deux nations qui se sont constituées au
fil des siècles et qui sont devenus
différentes un petit que la france et
l'allemagne est bien avec des origines
communes elles se sont différenciés dans
l'histoire c'est la même chose pour la
russie et pour l'ukraine et l'ukraine
affirme son identité politique depuis
trois siècles c'est un as a été
contestée par les russes hélas depuis
1991 l'ensemble de l'ukraine crimée et
d'une base comprise ont dit 'nous on
forme un état nation et il ya eu trois
maidan en 91 en 2004 et en 2014 où
l'ensemble de la nation s'est réuni pour
dire
nous on est une nation indépendante
on est pour la démocratie et on est pour
l'europe hélas ces trois derniers mois
la caisse qui s'est accélérée en ukraine
baisse qui s'est accélérée c'est que
cette nation indépendante européennes et
démocratiques alors qu'elle pouvait
encore se considérer comme ouverte à la
russie aujourd'hui c'est plus possible
aujourd'hui mes amis ukrainiens qui
étaient encore prêts à discuter avec moi
sur les différentes formes pour revenir
à la paix aujourd'hui ils veulent plus
en entendre parler ils veulent
simplement
que la vérité soit faite sur le passé
communiste sur la la la l' état mafieux
comme ils le disent de de la russie et
pour que justice soit faite par rapport
à tous ces crimes aujourd'hui encore une
fois je le répète les les russes ne
n'hésite pas à parler de génocide c'est
à dire de répéter ce qui s'est passé en
1932 contre l'ukraine le fameux golo de
mort ça fait 5 millions de morts ça veut
dire vingt mille morts par jour pendant
six mois il aura pas de pardon comme
sans justice aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas
de pardon s'il n'y a pas de vérité ni de
justice et donc c'est ça les états
occidentaux doivent être conscients de
ça les accords soit disant réaliste qui
sont
promus part de l'entourage du président
macron ou au quai d'orsay en réalité
c'est pas du tout du réalisme le
réalisme c'est d'être conscient que les
peuples ont besoin de vérité de justice
pour être intégré dans dans une europe
de paix c'est ça le vrai réalisme le
réalisme de courte vue et bien il
conduit aux guerres mondiales il faut
arrêter de dérouler le tapis rouge à au
dictateur parce que ça ne fait que les
encourager on entend votre inquiétude ce
matin merci beaucoup et votre expertise
on essaie de faire de la place dans
cette dans ce rendez vous d'info
al'expertise justement merci encore et
antoine est revenu ce matin sur le
plateau de paris direct le fil rouge de
cette matinée d'infos donc cette guerre
en ukraine qui entre ce mardi dans son
quatrième mois on y revient dans ce
journal de 8 heures et demie avec damien
coop y être
[Musique]